the Attorney General William bar says he
will not testify as scheduled before the
House Judiciary Committee this morning
eating up an already tense dispute with
congressional Democrats the Justice
Department says that committee chairman
Jerry Nadler plan to let staff lawyers
rather than members questioned the
Attorney General is inappropriate and
here's the big news today the committee
could vote today to hold Barr in
contempt of Congress for refusing
demands to hand over the unedited Muller
report Barr spent more than five hours
yesterday answering senators questions
about Robert Muller's investigation
Nancy Cordes covered it all and she's on
Capitol Hill at the scene of today's
potential hearing Nancy good morning
good morning potential hearing is Right
the House Democrats say this show must
go on so even if the Attorney General
does not show up they're going to hold
the hearing anyway but the committee
chairman said last night that he hoped
that the Attorney General would sleep on
it and decide to testify again today the
Attorney General has a nerve to try to
dictate and the administration is an
earth to dictate our procedures
Judiciary Committee Chairman Jerry
Nadler said Barr had balked at the
committee's plans to have both lawmakers
and expert staffers question him about
the Muller report a set up Republicans
called unreasonable bill Barr was not
coming to the circus that was actually
presented to us today in a Senate
hearing Wednesday Democrats grilled bar
about the letter he received from
special counsel robert muller
complaining that bar did not fully
capture the substance of Muller's report
the letters a bit snitty and i think it
was probably written by one of his staff
people senators pushed bar to explain
his decision not to charge the president
with obstruction of justice you did not
question or look at the underlying
evidence that supports the conclusions
in the report no the report found that
the president's personal counsel told
Paul mana for that he would be quote
taken care of that you don't consider
obstruction of justice so discouraging
flipping in that sense is not
obstruction a president essentially
tries to change the lawyers account in
order to prevent further
criticism of himself well that's not a
crime Democrats also questioned the
Attorney General about his conversations
with the White House has the President
or anyone at the White House ever asked
or suggested that you open an
investigation of anyone yes or no please
sir the president or anybody else seems
you would remember something like that
and be able to tell us yeah but I'm
trying to grapple with the word suggest
I don't know I wouldn't say suggest
hinted I don't know inferred you don't
know okay after that exchange
California's Kamala Harris joined a
growing group of Democrats calling on
bar to resign our President Trump had
nothing but praise for his new Attorney
General it's so ridiculous he's an
outstanding man he's an outstanding
legal mind
Republicans defended him - enough
already
is over but House Democrats say they are
just getting started and they are going
to consider holding Barr in contempt of
Congress if he doesn't testify here
today they're also calling on robert
muller himself to testify on May 15th
Norah I got lots to come Nancy thank you